day is tomorrow in the california recall
president biden heading to the state to
campaign with governor gavin newsom
later today this is top gop challenger
larry elder is continuing his campaign
against the governor let's bring in
martha mccallum anchor of the story
straight from los angeles she's there
for special coverage of the recall
election hey martha
hey there jackie so the president is out
there trying to save newsome seat
what do you see as the biggest causes of
this recall how likely is it that newsom
hangs on given some of the recent
polling that shows that really
republicans
are pretty much
directly in support of this democrats
not so much and it's a deeply blue state
but this has been
was once seen as a long shot coming to
pass now
yeah this is it's so fascinating because
as you say jackie
democrats outnumber republicans in the
state of california two to one
nevertheless there was this shocking
sort of groundswell enough
about two million people signed
petitions to recall governor newsom and
that all happened during the heat of
covid during his evening out at the
french laundry when people just really
started to get ticked off feeling that
there were rules for him rules for thee
but not for me right and their kids were
stuck at home their businesses were
closing uh enormous numbers of small
businesses many of them owned um by by
minority like black latino store owners
in california have lost their businesses
over the course of this so it's a very
interesting litmus test in terms of what
we see in turnout what we see in terms
of how how aggravated people are with
all of that it's obviously an uphill
battle there's 46 republican or 46
candidates who are running against
gavin newsom not all of them republicans
but
he is obviously bringing in the big guns
he's got president biden coming in
for a speech this evening at a rally
tonight kamala harris was here on friday
um but larry elder is not giving up he
is in the front position he's got about
26 by the most recent estimates in terms
of the turnout but one of the
interesting things for people to keep in
mind here is that that gavin newsom just
needs to cross that 50
plus a vote threshold in order to hang
on to the governor's seat but if he
loses that if he gets 49 percent of the
vote someone on the other side say larry
elder or caitlyn jenner or kevin
falconer they could win the vote with
just 20 with the plurality of the
remaining so that's why one of the
things that you're hearing from gavin
newsom today is just vote just vote know
and go he says just vote no recall and
then leave just walk out after you put
that ballot in the in the ballot box
because he doesn't want people going to
the second part of that question which
says if not gavin newsom who would you
like to see replace it right as you
mentioned so much of this is a
referendum on newsome's handling of
kovid so how much for instance is larry
elder's opposition to things like
vaccine mandates fueling energy around
this recall
yeah i think you nailed it i think the
thing is that gavin newsom wants people
to forget about his handling of kovid
the situation has improved here in terms
of cases so he's saying this is a
republican recall is what he's calling
it and he's saying you know this is an
anti-vaxxer thing this is anti-abortion
this is a trump vote all of that is what
he's throwing into the mix because
there's a growing number of independent
voters in california there's also an
interesting um sort of momentum and
latino voters that's going to be you've
seen larry elder spending a lot of time
trying to convince latino voters that
they should vote to recall gavin newsom
so those are kind of the interesting
areas to keep an eye on here those
independent voters the latino voters and
do they show
even if they don't succeed in in
recalling news and what are they showing
in terms of the momentum in california
overall where a lot of people are really
fed up with the direction of this
absolutely beautiful state amazing
history they've got a homeless problem
that's going through the roof crime is
increasing and businesses are just
having trouble functioning given the
structure
and lack of enticements to begin and
open and grow companies here yeah going
out to like a bird's eye view what is at
stake vice president harris said that
this is about sending a message that
democrats can keep control of both
chambers ahead of the midterms she's
claiming that the results would
reverberate down impact reproductive
rights immigration etc
anyone who replaces newsome would have
to contend with the democratic super
majority in the state legislature but
could it in fact send the message that
the vice president is talking about
i think that's why you see such big
firepower coming out here to back gavin
newsom from the president on down the
vice president uh president former
president obama put in a video message
here for gavin newsom i think there's a
little bit of concern i think they are a
bit worried as they look towards the
midterms about some of these trends
about this enormous bill that is moving
its way through the house three and a
half trillion dollars which really comes
out to about five and a half trillion in
spending taxation has been through the
roof here you see a lot of businesses
moving to places like austin and
nashville leaving california they've had
a decline in their population here for
the first time in the state's history
this is the place where people wanted to
come
where there was independence and freedom
to start your own life to start your own
business to to you know have that sort
of western future and outlook um and
that's that's changed here in california
that sort of can-do spirit is really uh
has really altered over the last 25
years so i i think it's going to be very
interesting to see the underlying
dynamics of this vote as it starts
getting counted tomorrow and how much
turnout is there tomorrow how many
people are waiting to put those ballots
in the box on the day of the election
tuesday september 14th so we're keeping
a close eye on it it's gonna be
fascinating to watch excited to watch
your coverage of it martha thank you so
much appreciate your time thanks jackie
and of course we'll see martha three
o'clock hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not gonna miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now